what's up samantha how are you doing i
am six months pregnant
with my third child and
um how old are the other ones uh
i have a two and a half year old and a
one-year-old oh
my two yeah and a half
and one and a six month in the oven
yeah i would just like on behalf of
humanity to
say god bless you i don't even i don't
even know what to say after that other
than
okay go forward go ahead
got our hands full yes well my
husband came to me recently and he
told me that he was with someone else
and um that he
probably contracted an std and that i
most likely have it as well
and so i've gone and been tested and
that is
the case um
yeah you're confirmed positive holy crap
i'm so sorry
that sucks
what's the what's the sti
uh it's uh chlamydia so it's something
that's um
treatable thankfully golly i'm so sorry
so have you gone to your ob gyn to talk
through any implications with your
pregnancy
um yeah walk me through that
um basically i'll just do the treatment
and um
it should clear up and we just have to
do some follow-up
just to make sure that everything is um
normal and healthy and then it should
not
it'll be like it never happened oh man
i'm so sorry
yeah but it did happen right yeah yeah
so i'm going to ask you to do something
weird as we talk through this okay
i want to take the sti part and i want
to set that off to the side for a second
okay and i want to take the
overjoyed exhausted i haven't slept
in what four years now when you add in
all the pregnancies completely exhausted
at a
psychological and spiritual and physical
level right
and then to get this news because what i
don't want to do as we as we walk
through this i don't want
that um the consequence of what happened
to be the focus just yet i don't want to
get back to
this conversation y'all had tell me how
the conversation went
um basically he just came and he told me
like this happened
and now um like i'm
having symptoms and it was just
kind of all just very surreal um i
i didn't see it coming at all okay total
total shock to you
oh yeah i mean i would have never
guessed in a million years that
he would have done something like that
and so
how can i help there's so much here how
can i help
i mean it just my
i know my family is like well like
obviously like you
just you leave and like of course and
you know they're like
and i mean that's
not necessarily like the thing that i
mean i want
i have i mean i've i came from a very
broken family and
i didn't want my kids to be raised in
that
i didn't want them to ever
feel that and um so now i've just got
a very big decision of where i go from
here yeah
what do you want to do forget with your
parents and your family and all the
people
telling you what you're going to tell
you you're going to have people that
will sit you down and buy you a cup of
coffee
and look you in the eye and say i know
this is heartbreaking but
you and your husband have a future
together you're gonna get through this
if y'all both want to and you can do the
hard work and then you're gonna have
somebody call you and be like
oh you're just gonna be a cuckold for
the rest of your life you're just gonna
let him do you know what i mean so
forget all those voices and and also
forget the and it's gonna sound
ridiculous forget
the um fantasy that you had
about i want my kids to have this
because i had another
picture right i had another experience
in my life so i painted this picture
that's gonna happen no matter what
because that might force that might
encourage you to drag yourself through
mud that you don't need to go through
right um
what do you want to do put all those
things down and just talk to me
directly what do you want to do
um i mean i i do want
to work things out like you know i still
love him and i
he said it was a one-time thing and i i
genuinely believed that it was
have y'all gone to see anybody um
no i've got some it's coming up
scheduled
okay is he when you say
um he told us a one-time thing and
he came to you with this is he still all
in is he
say i screwed up i'm so sorry i'm going
to make this right here's all my phones
here's all my computer stuff i want you
to know
i am i am this is this is an accident
happened
and i'm going to do anything it takes to
repair this and not even repair to
rebuild you got to rebuild something new
now right
um what's his heart and space on this
i mean he's just i mean apologizing
to me about like 5 000 million times a
day and
he called a marriage counselor and just
tried to get everything
hooked up and he's he's
he's trying and he's you know like you
can track me here's all my passwords
here's all my everything and
um so you believe him
as much as you can right i mean after
that's like you've had like the deepest
violation hurt right and so i know that
sounds trite be like all right cool
you're ready to get back on that horse
and ride again i get that
um but your gut tells you
but i i genuinely just i mean i hope i
mean
you know i in my gut i feel like it
really was just
a single incident okay so
here's the thing you owe nobody an
explanation
for choosing to stay with them you owe
nobody an explanation for
choosing to um give it a shot
to try and when you have this
third baby and when you have some time
to actually grieve
and when you have time to process this
and to
like let the um you know the the
fight-or-flight response right that
shock wear off and you actually can look
in the eye and say
dude you could have hurt us both bad
because you violated us
and you were stupid when you did it um
and you choose you know what i gave it
six months i'm out i gave it
you know 10 months and i can't you don't
owe anybody an explanation then
and if you choose to bail tomorrow you
don't have anybody explanation for that
okay
i want you to feel free from that and
everybody's gonna have an opinion
remember when you first got pregnant the
first time
how many stupid advice droplet
droplets that sounds like a sneeze but
it's basically what it is it's just snot
everyone's stopping like okay make sure
you've got somebody to text and make
sure
this and you should use this remember
those days
oh yeah that's what's coming except 10
times worse because
everyone feels on moral high ground on
this one so they're all going to give
you their
girl uni it's all it's common dude so um
i mean i always thought it would be a
no-brainer for me and i would just i was
like that's an obviously come out
like yeah you just would just of course
you leave but
and i was just i was just talking to
somebody recently and they said the
opposite they were like i just knew
that if that ever happened we'd work
through it and we'd move on
and then they said it happened and it's
like i'm out
like i just knew in my guts that was
that that was that right
so here's a couple of things i'll
recommend number one is
um you've got to have somebody privately
that you can grieve this with
okay i can hear it in you
like this is an existential thing this
is a thing you swore would never happen
this is a thing you've probably leaned
really hard into
making sure that your family stayed
together this is a
a what i call like a grave soul injury
and not in a
overly spiritual kind of way but this is
something that rocks people to their
absolute core okay so
yes you need to go to marriage
counseling y'all got to work on that
immediately but you need somebody that
you can talk to
privately as well okay the second thing
is this
you can't recreate what was now you've
got to build something completely new
the language that they use that i love
the metaphor that
i i use all the time is this
when the twin towers fell down they
couldn't sweep up all that glass and
steel
and metal and tape it and glue it all
back together and recreate those towers
they had to excavate the whole site
throw that stuff in the dump
and build something completely new and
what they built new is beautiful and
stunning and extraordinary and strong
and will last for hundreds of years but
you had to
do the hard work of getting architecture
designs and engineering and redo the
whole thing
okay and so you're on a journey now to
build something completely new
and what i see happens with couples a
lot when they're trying to recover from
some sort of violation like this is they
try to get what was back and
that you can't and so you end up feeling
like you're failing instead of saying
okay that's over
we are now starting again and we're
gonna have to rebuild something
completely new
and i know that's exhausting and hard
not the thing you want to do with three
kids
under three right um yeah and then the
other thing man is you're gonna have to
have to have to and this is gonna sound
like i'm flipping sides here please hear
my heart on this
okay if you are making a go of it
you got to choose grace and not to
weaponize everything around
around you around your husband around
your ecosystem okay
because at the end of the day you're
going to just poison yourself hoping he
dies
and that's not gonna be how that works
okay
okay i'm heartbroken for you um
so i just gave you some things that like
here's what it's gonna look like to
rebuild and you're talking
years okay you're talking months and
years this is a big deal
not to mention the consequence of it all
are you in
you're pretty awesome samantha
you're pretty awesome i know this sucks
and i know this hurts
i'm so so sorry for you
call somebody today somebody that's not
going to give you advice it's not going
to overwhelm you with
well you know what you should so i'm
just going to be with you and listen and
if that's a professional great
if you got that friend great
i'm so sorry i wish i could end this
call on a positive note everybody go get
them
rocks you know rock and roll and
fireworks
but this just sucks folks remember man
your actions
my dad used to say it's like throwing a
brick throwing a rock
in the lake and those ripple effects
you know they end up on shores way far
away you threw that rock right over
there man but it ends up
affecting the shoreline way across the
other side
and i know being married with young kids
is really hard and i know
being married young kids is lonely i
know being
i mean i can't even imagine i can't wrap
my head around three kids under the age
of three
um that's disney world in a circus in a
really small space
but man stay true
don't cheat stay true stay true man
don't cheat stay true